and New York magazine correspondent
Gabriel DeBenedetti joins us Gabe good
morning I know you're a little hoarse
this morning but thanks thanks for being
here
we just heard Lindsey Graham call this a
mistake so the Republicans who are very
uncomfortable with the president said
what's the fallout in general been well
you have a lot of people who are
uncomfortable with this Republicans have
said it was a mistake but most of the
president's allies have not said much at
all Democrats have been really raising
alarms here they say that this is
essentially an invitation to foreign
governments to meddle in the elections
and the president has essentially said
no we're not worried about that anymore
it's a long way from no collusion the
president did clarify his position
yesterday but did was that clarification
enough or did he just feed more into the
the ammo
she was critics it was a bit of a
clarification but he essentially said no
I would do it even if it wasn't you know
most of the material wasn't that bad so
it wasn't much of a real clarification
again I'm old enough to remember what he
was saying no collusion now he's saying
you know you can talk to foreign
governments most of the time it's kind
of okay long lines for Democrats though
did it
just reinvigorate those who are looking
towards impeachment there are certainly
those who say this is yet more evidence
that this president is lawless and unfit
to govern but Nancy Pelosi who of course
is in charge of this whole process is
essentially saying the majority of my
caucus is not there yet this is not
going to be the thing that pushes us
over the edge but there's no doubt that
pressure is increasing from the left
let's turn to the president's assertion
that Iran was behind the attack of two
tankers how serious is this situation
become to youth yeah well we don't
actually know because the president
keeps saying something more is coming
but we have no idea what that something
is there seems to be a divide among his
allies particularly among people in the
White House about what comes next
but it's very clear that there are a lot
of Democrats and Republicans and
international allies that are trying to
ratchet tensions down there are a lot of
people who are saying we don't want to
go down to a war go down the road to war
with Iran we don't know yeah I'm for
this for me this is this is big because
if you attack a u.s. vessel right that
that's reason for war how why aren't
they saying how they know it's Iran for
sure well the president says he knows
that it's Iran but of course there are
there's a clear divide in Washington as
to how real this intelligence is
obviously this is all very
sensitive I suspect that we're going to
get a lot more information about this in
the coming days or at least there will
be a lot of pressure for this
information because of course there's
nothing that Republican and Democratic
lawmakers in Washington are more wary of
these days then calls for war calls for
ratcheting up tension with an adversary
with so little Intel and Gabe they've
learned I know Charlie mentioned the war
in the 80s that tanker war in eighties
there's something that has been gleaned
from that that can be used now well of
course a lot of it a lot of the Intel is
very sketchy right now and so they're
just trying to look back at that but
also you know other words that have
happened since then other situations
where there were attacks that weren't
really clear where it was from so there
you have a lot of people in Washington
trying to look back at that and say well
obviously we didn't escalate tensions to
a full war then we don't want to do that
now gave the official lineups for the
first democratic debate have been set 20
candidates appearing over two nights to
zero yeah and actually some got left out
which is that's right yeah pretty rough
but so what do you think the strategy
for the Dems going in here has to be
well it depends obviously candidates a
candidate but you have nine other people
on stage with you everyone's gonna be
trying to have a breakout moment
particularly if you're one of these
candidates who's not that well-known ya
know there are a lot of heavyweights on
each of the nights you know the major
candidates but if you're someone who we
don't really talk about that much on TV
you're going to be trying to have a
moment or something that really makes
you stand out is this a make-or-break
moment for some of these tenders
absolutely cuz they're gonna run out of
money they're gonna rout of attention
soon if not all right Gabe wrest the
voice we appreciate you powering through